our kids are great you have a a
beautiful life together we got lucky
with our kids they're they're easy I
always tell my kids you make it so easy
to be a
dad just they're just good kids they
really are they're they're great and I
think they're like their mom I don't
think we pretend to be perfect either I
think we're all human that's why I love
your tattoo I was lucky to meet uh to
have my brother and then to meet cam
they have a beautiful relationship they
do to have this like growing family of
good people that all are also all
imperfect and not trying to like present
like we have it all figured out but we
work on ourselves and you guys all work
on yourselves like I you know I know
therapy yeah I know each one of you
together and individually the
therapy